amerika ist aufgewühlt
eine gesellschaft bringt mit seiner
erbsünde wie kämpfen schwarze im jahr
2020 gegen rassismus wir fordern ein
neues amerika in dem meine kinder unsere
kinder leben und gedeihen können
der tod von george chlorid reißt alte
wunden neu auch immer wieder
polizeigewalt gegen schwarze was heißt
es schwarzen amerika zu sein
es ist beschissen ein schwarzer mann so
seien alle hassen dich die namenslisten
der opfer sind lang
[Musik]
schwarzes leben ausgelöscht
kollektives trauma
wie können wir zurückbekommen was sie
uns gestohlen haben
[Musik]
wie weit ist amerika bereits zu gehen um
der polizei gewalt ein ende zu setzen
mein ziel ist eine welt ohne polizei und
gefängnisse ein moment der die
amerikanische gesellschaft herausfordert
schwarz und weiß
weiße müssen jetzt kämpfen schwarze
haben schon so viel gekämpft
[Applaus]
es ist sein lebensinhalt in diesem
sommer 2020 demonstrieren marschieren
kundgebung teil hobson paul hat eine
mission
gerechtigkeit kommt die nicht wollen sie
das alte amerika abschaffen
[Applaus]
washington dc amerikas hauptstadt hier
wie im ganzen land seit monaten
demonstrationen eine breite bewegung die
keinen anführer braucht gemeinsam wollen
sie stark sein
hier sind die bewegung sie wird nicht
mit einem von uns leben oder sterben
diese revolution gedeiht mit uns allen
zusammen bei und seine konzern citizens
junge aktivisten spontan schlossen sie
sich nach dem tod von george roy
zusammen seither protestieren sie mit 24
hat teil bereits zwei uni abschlüsse er
kommt aus einer mittelschicht familie
trotzdem rassismus trifft auch wenn ich
in diesem amerika als schwarzer in einer
weißen gegend in einem kapuzen pulli
unterwegs bin dann bin ich ein
potenzielles opfer ich werde als
krimineller wahrgenommen
ich bin es leid angst zu haben wir
wollen keine angst mehr haben
das gründungs motto amerikas alle
menschen sind gleich
habe immer nur für weiße gegolten bis
heute werden schwarze als bürger zweiter
klasse behandelt sagt 155 jahre nach
ende der sklaverei zeit amerika neu zu
erfinden
wir können uns nicht erlauben politisch
zu sein
sieben tage die woche 365 tage im jahr
bin ich schwarz wir rufen nach einem
neuen amerika denn dieses amerika
schützt niemand anders als den weißen
markt der moment der alles verändert das
video von coach fritz für viele im land
ein weckruf
minneapolis ende mai die festnahme die
für floyd tödlich endet acht minuten und
46 sekunden unter dem knie des weissen
polizisten minneapolis brennt in den
nächten nach floyds tot
die wut richtet sich vor allem gegen die
polizei hier wie in den gesamten usa
wird der ruf laut die funte police
entzieht der polizei das geld und das
personal die polizeistation geht in
flammen auf
eine ruine bleibt zurück für die
aktivistin kenntnis ein gutes bild dafür
was geschehen muss
unter den black metal demonstranten
steht sie für die radikale position eine
welt ganz ohne polizei ihre vision
ich mag dies als sichtbares symbol dass
wir in eine neue ära übergehen in ein
neues modell für öffentliche sicherheit
wir wollen nicht ein hübscheres gebäude
sondern das alte abreißen und etwas
neues bauen kenntnis will ein umdenken
öffentliche sicherheit ginge auch ohne
polizei sogar besser sagt sie
das budget der polizei müsse umgeleitet
werden in andere töpfe wir haben aber
millionen von dollar in die polizei
investiert als allheilmittel für
öffentliche sicherheit
aber wir haben noch nicht begonnen
anteilig auch in andere dinge zu
investieren die uns viel er sicher sein
lassen
wohnen jobs bildung und
gesundheitsvorsorge für alle
seit jahren schon kämpfen kenntnis und
ihre mitstreiter für eine abschaffung
der polizei der tod floyds verschaffte
ihnen landesweit gehört in minneapolis
eine weile so aus als würde ihre vision
wirklichkeit im letzten moment aber
machte die stadt einen rückzieher den
bürgermeister konfrontiert kenntnis auf
einer kundgebung mit der entscheidenden
frage
[Applaus]
ja oder nein entziehen sie der polizei
die gelder der bürgermeister er verneint
[Musik]
er werde die abschaffung der
polizeibehörde nicht unterstützen
unter buhrufen jagd candice team vom
platz eine lange schon gärende wut ist
mit gewalt zurück auf die straße
gekommen
landesweit und nachhaltig demonstrieren
tausende so brutal der tod von george
freut dazu das feindbild im weißen haus
präsident trump hört nicht was die
demonstranten sagen er spricht von
inländischem terrorismus aus seinem
wahlkampf wird ein kultur kampf wir sind
die partei für recht und ordnung
der präsident schickte hundertschaften
heizt die proteste an und schürt angst
demonstranten als feinde amerikas
das sind keine demonstranten das sind
anarchisten unruhestifter randalierer
plünderer
trump stellt sich hinter die polizei
nutzt die proteste um bei seinen wählern
zu punkten
rassismus in der polizei gibt es für ihn
nicht dabei gibt es bereits städte im
land die beginnen strukturen zu
verändern
die zukunft der polizei wie kann und
soll sie aussehen
denn was bürgermeister weiß dass es so
nicht weitergehen kann er will reform
untergehakt mit demonstranten war er
unterwegs auf den protesten denn auch er
hat aggressive polizisten erlebt das
prägt ihn bis heute
man muss sich daran erinnern dass in
amerika die polizei ursprünglich dazu da
war sklaven unter kontrolle zu halten
und diese werte sind nach wie vor tief
im system verankert
wir müssen 450 jahre tradition
rückgängig machen
da kommt viel hoch ein durcheinander von
gefährlichen vorurteilen besonders gegen
schwarze die polizei im ganzen land ist
unter druck auch in denver nach
monatelangen protesten ist der
polizeichef bereit ihre form zu
versuchen abschaffen will er sich nicht
wir müssen wieder vertrauen aufbauen und
die beziehung zu den menschen
wir müssen zusammenarbeiten um lösungen
zu finden und die art von polizei die
die menschen wollen
ich höre sie wollen nicht keine polizei
oder weniger polizei sondern bessere
polizei im rahmen eines modellprojekts
gliedert denn war einige aufgaben der
polizei aus seit juni werden ausgewählte
notrufe umgeleitet dieses medizinische
team rückt anstelle der polizei aus in
die seelische verfassung eines menschen
ins wanken geraten ist besser
ausgebildet sind sie dafür eine
eskalation daher unwahrscheinlich
wenn wir zu diesen einsätzen fahren
gehen wir ganz anders auf die menschen
zu
wir fragen wie wir sie unterstützen
können ich mache klar ich bin nicht der
gesetzeshüter auch nicht das krankenhaus
system wir wollen dich nicht
niederdrücken nur helfen
knapp 400 mal sind sie bislang gefahren
kamerateams dürfen nicht mit zum einsatz
in diesem aufgeheizten sommer wurde das
denver projekt schnell zum vorbild der
fokus des neuen teams liegt auf
psychisch instabilen personen
doch der bürgermeister weiß die
kombination von psychischer krise und
polizei ist besonders für schwarze
gefährlich mixt man eine psychische
störung zusammen mit aggressivem
verhalten und der voreingenommenheit der
polizei und hat dann jemanden der in
stabil ist dann hat man das rezept für
eine katastrophe
kein einziges mal musste das
medizinerteam bisher die polizei zur
unterstützung rufen nicht für jeden
einsatz so ihre erste bilanz ist die
polizei die beste antwort
george floyd nur einer von so vielen
fällen von polizeibrutalität juli 2016
fahrzeugkontrolle in einem vorort von
minneapolis für viel an doka stil endet
sie tödlich
seinen führerschein wollte er aus der
tasche ziehen der polizist aber dachte
er greife nach einer waffe john thompson
war der beste freund von vielen
er wünscht sich viel an da hätte eine
andere route gewählt weiße polizisten
würden hier besonders oft schwarze
anhalten auch ohne anlass
er wurde genau hier ermordet da war der
polizist
wieviel ando sein auto er hatte nur noch
einen block bis zur schnellinger video
wäre er da rechts abgebogen dann wäre
alles glatt gegangen
john trauert um viel ando der wahl
kantinen mitarbeiter und ohne vorstrafen
doch für die polizisten war er wegen
seiner hautfarbe vor allem eines eine
bedrohung
sie sehen in uns was anderes als in euch
es ist so beschissen ein schwarzer mann
zu sein es fühlt sich an als würde jeder
dich hassen als hättest du immer eine
zielscheibe auf deinem rücken
schwarze werden in den usa doppelt so
häufig wie weiße von der polizei getötet
allein 2020 kamen bisher landesweit
knapp 170 schwarze durch polizeigewalt
ums leben
für john vermeidbar hätte man sich nur
nach viel landes tot zu echten reformen
durchgerungen
[Musik]
wir hatten schon damals gefordert dass
polizisten rechenschaft ablegen müssen
für ihr tun
wir verlangten wirksame maßnahmen aber
alles was dann kam waren kurse zur
deeskalation und vorurteilen viel zu
wenig viele kriegt sechs kugeln ab und
die machen nur ein pflaster drüber sein
frust entlädt sich auf einer
demonstration gegen die polizei immer
wieder abprallen ein weißer macht ich
hab's satt immer nur zu reden zu
marschieren nicht ernst genommen zu
werden bewegen wir unsere erste also ins
kapitol ins verdammte rathaus in den
stadtrat
genau das will er jetzt einen sitz im
landesparlament
john macht wahlkampf unterwegs mit
seinem sohn der soll es mal besser haben
als schwarze heute john will
entscheidungen nicht mehr anderen
überlassen er will nun selbst am tisch
der entscheider platz nehmen
mama wellen and john die mutter von
vielen castiel valery sie hat andere
frauen geladen die wie sie angehörige
durch polizeigewalt verloren haben ihre
söhne brüder oder männer valery will
eine stütze für sie seien frauen
verbundenen schmerz ich nenne das hier
den beschissenen mütter club beschissen
dass es uns gibt mütter die um ihre
kinder trauern müssen
fotos ihrer lieben tragen sie um den
hals
sie wollen dass ihre akten neu
aufgemacht werden in nur einem prozent
der fälle von polizeigewalt kommt es zu
einer anklage sie hoffen dass der tod
von george freut die nation aufrüttelt
dass das video den menschen die augen
öffnet dass sie nicht länger weg sehen
können
bislang hat man uns ja immer gesagt auch
das kann doch nicht so schlimm sein
kommt drüber weg solche dinge aber wenn
man es selbst sehen kann dann springt es
einem ins gesicht dann gibt es kein
leugnen mehr was mit unseren schwarzen
kindern da draußen passiert du kannst
nicht abstreifen hast du mit eigenen
augen gesehen hast die landesweiten
proteste die auf das brutale video
folgten für sie nachvollziehbarer
ausdruck aufgestauter wut nicht
verstehen können sie die empörung über
ausschreitungen
die leute schätzen ihre gebäude ihren
besitz mehr als menschen leben
uns haben sie menschenleben gestohlen
ihre gebäude können sie wieder aufbauen
die kriegen sie zurück wie aber bekomme
nur zurück was ihr uns gestohlen haben
sie sind es leid angst um ihre schwarzen
söhne und männer zu haben wenn die auf
der straße unterwegs sind sie fragen wie
lange noch müssen wir unsere kinder
drinnen für begegnungen mit der polizei
eine feste lehrstunde in schwarzen
haushalten polizei als bedrohung nicht
als freund und helfer
diese lehrstunde musst du ihnen leider
geben
ihrer hautfarbe und weil wir in
jahrzehnten erlebt haben schwarze männer
sind eine zielscheibe um dein kind zu
schützen musst du dich mit ihm hinsetzen
und sagen auch ein star ist auch wenn du
es nicht versendet aber du musst das und
das tun damit du sicher bist siehst
schwarzes viertel in washington
hier sind die streetworker die junge
männer aufs leben vorbereiten wollen die
konzerne eine initiative von
sozialarbeitern die selbst hier
aufgewachsen sind wie bei einem
chirurgischen eingriff verwandeln wir
hochrisiko jungs in jemanden mit
niedrigem oder gar keinem risiko
wir verstehen sie denn wir waren mal wie
sie wir wissen so wollen sie nicht sein
sie passen sich einfach ihre umgebung an
das ist alles was sie kennen
über 90 prozent der menschen hier sind
schwarz armut schlechte schulen kaum
freizeitangebote stattdessen drogen
waffen und gangs
schnell gerät man hier auf die schiefe
bahn
viele schwarze brauchen bildung aber die
kriegen sie nicht und dann landen sie
auf der straße
die proteste für sie ganz weit weg der
tägliche überlebenskampf kostet zu viel
kraft eine der größten herausforderungen
für mich ist die armut auch da helfen
die konzerne
sie verteilen essen wenn wir nichts
haben und sie vermitteln uns
ansprechpartner für jobs und so das
finde ich gut denn sie haben denselben
kampf wie wir geführt
washington ist klar in schwarze und
weiße viertel getrennt wo man geboren
wird entscheidet über die zukunft
wer in sound ist groß wird hat kaum
chancen heraus zu kommen
viele hürden sind nicht offen sichtbar
perspektivlosigkeit über generationen
gewachsen
die leute hier kämpfen mit emotionaler
armut noch mehr als mit materieller auch
sie fühlen sich als wären sie nichts
wert sind hoffnungslos diese emotionale
armut ist so stark negative einflüsse
können da schnell greifen immer wieder
drücken sie dich runter lassen dich
nicht in die tür sagen dafür willst du
nicht qualifiziert
diese rückschläge die die leute
hinnehmen müssen das macht was mit dir
die konzern man wissen wovon sie
sprechen sie haben all das selbst erlebt
eine welt in der schießereien und gewalt
als normal gelten
nun wollen sie als mentoren zeigen es
gibt auch eine andere welt auch john
haben die streetworker gerettet wegen
mordes saß er 18 jahre
nun ist er einer von ihnen ich habe die
gegend hier für ein paar jahre mit
eingerissen als ich jung war
nun mach ich es wieder gut wenn was
zurückgeben ich versuche wieder
aufzubauen was ich zerstört habe
[Musik]
pennsylvania landwirtschaft viehzucht
mittendrin lancaster kleinstadt mit
knapp 60.000 einwohnern
doch selbst in dieser idylle lebt die
historische trennung in schwarze und
weiße stadtviertel fort stadtrat easy
und die von der planungskommission
unterwegs in der altstadt restauriert
teuer und weiß wie von einer
unsichtbaren mauer getrennt vom
schwarzenviertel sie wollen die spaltung
von lancaster aufheben die grenze
durchlässiger machen
landesweit wurden schwarze über
jahrzehnte auf bestimmte stadtteile
beschränkt per gesetz das wirkt bis
heute nach
diese kreuzung ist so eine art
eingangstor zum südosten
das viertel ist überwiegend auf
amerikanisch und latino geprägt da gibt
es eher sozialen wohnungsbau heute haben
wir eine stadt in der einige menschen
überhaupt nicht die möglichkeit haben zu
leben wo sie wollen
trennung nach wirtschaftlicher situation
ist eng verknüpft mit der trennung nach
haut
demonstriert wurde in diesem jahr vor
allem gegen polizeibrutalität doch wie
wollt ihr sie wissen es gibt auch stille
gewalt gegen schwarze die die
jahrzehntelange vernachlässigung von
stadtteilen wir verdammen die menschen
dort praktisch zu sterben zu einem
schlimmen leben in blei verseuchten
appartements mit schmutzigen trinkwasser
das ist eine form der gewalt ich will
ein lancaster wo jeder wohnen kann wo er
will
ihr plan preiswerte wohnungen in jedem
neuen bauprojekt so sollen weiße viertel
auch für schwarze erschwinglich werden
sieht sich in der verantwortung erst
recht als weiße
die proteste dieses jahres ein weckruf
für sie das privileg ihrer hautfarbe
will sie nutzen was historisch gewachsen
ist zu korrigieren dass wir uns die mühe
machen in uns gehen und uns dieses
privileg bewusst machen und uns fragen
wie wir rassismus angehen können
das ist für mich zum moralischen
imperativ geworden
wie kann man nicht sehen was gerade
passiert und keinen druck verspüren die
dinge zu verändern
virtuelle sitzung der planungskommission
von lancaster ehrenamtlich in ihrer
freizeit engagiert sich die professorin
für umweltwissenschaften gegen die
unsichtbare grenze in der stadt
ich weiß es ist nur ein kleiner
mosaikstein im kampf gegen den rassismus
dennoch ist sie voll hoffnung
[Musik]
die zukunft und an vielen fronten düster
aus so wird die wirtschaftskrise
ungleichheit zwischen den hautfarben
aber hoffnung zu haben bedeutet ja aktiv
zu werden um die welt besser zu machen
sie tanzen und singen wie jeden sonntag
auch wenn der gottesdienst corona
bedingt draußen auf dem parkplatz
stattfindet die gemeindemitglieder der
therme lodge in einem vorort von atlanta
tief im süden der usa schwarze kirchen
traditionell setzen sie sich für
bürgerrechte ein pasta timothy animiert
seine gemeinde kurz vor der wahl
wie viele von euch haben sich bereits
für die wahl registriert registriert
euch wir wollen doch ein paar dinge hier
ändern
schwarze machen über 30 prozent der
wähler in georgia aus eine wichtige
wählergruppe die mit überwiegender
mehrheit die demokratische partei wählt
das macht sie zur zielscheibe einer
politik die sie von bohnen gang abhalten
will
wir nennen das systemischen rassismus
sowie das system funktioniert drängt es
wähler raus hauptsächlich afroamerikaner
es hindert uns daran zu wählen und teil
des prozesses zu sein
das erkennen wir und deshalb gehen wir
das als gemeinde an
[Musik]
der süden der usa 1 zog er für das recht
auf sklaven gegen den norden in den
bürgerkrieg auch nach dem ende der
sklaverei zementierte der süden durch
gesetze den status von schwarzen als
bürger zweiter klasse
das halt nach
bis heute gibt es versuche schwarze vom
wählen abzuhalten besonders in georgia
wo es bald eine nicht weiße mehrheit
geben wird eine mehrheit die von
republikanern als bedrohung empfunden
wird
bei den vorwahlen im juni wurde zb in
schwarzen bezirken die anzahl der
wahllokale reduziert die auflagen
verschärft sich auszuweisen und die
briefwahl erschwert ein fiasko
endlose schlangen abgewiesene wähler die
rechtfertigung der republikanischen
landesregierung man wollte wahlbetrug
vorbeugen dass es wahlbetrug gibt ist
eine behauptung der rechten damit
rechtfertigen sie solche maßnahmen
tatsächlich dienen sie aber dazu
schwarze stimmen zu unterdrücken
der einzige weg für sie weiterhin zu
gewinnen ist zu betrügen das new yorker
project will dagegenhalten mit massiver
wahlbeteiligung von schwarzen wollen sie
den effekt solcher tricks ausgleichen
die direktoren erwartet für die
präsidentschaftswahl im november erneut
wähler unterdrückung
wir brauchen eine überwältigende
wahlbeteiligung um allein nur die wähler
unterdrückung zu neutralisieren von der
wir heute schon wissen
und so schwärmen sie aus es gilt so
viele menschen wie möglich als wähler zu
registrieren
in einem land in dem man sich fürs
wählen ein schreiben muss wahlhelfer
josua berichte von seiner mutter deren
wahllokal kurzfristig verlegt wurde und
von seiner tochter deren
briefwahlunterlagen nicht akzeptiert
wurden
das ist doch nur ein weiteres beispiel
wie sie versuchen
ich hoffe sehr dass das nicht zu viele
menschen von der stimmabgabe abhält die
angst habe ich die wirkung dieser wähler
unterdrückung ist immens denn einmal
entmutigt kehrt der wähler oft nicht
wieder bei so vielen hürden setzt leicht
ein psychologischer effekt ein
die leute glauben dass ihre stimme
ähnlich zeit dass sie keine vollwertigen
bürger sind es fügt unserer demokratie
nachhaltigen schaden zu es kann das ende
unserer demokratie sein
im halben jahr nach dem tod von george
floyd hat sich was bewegt statuen der
unterdrücker der vergangenen
jahrhunderte niedergerissen
beim nascar autorin die konfigurierten
flagge verboten
der sport kniet und nimmt anteil
junge progressive schwarze politiker
kommen weiter und der kandidat der
demokraten geht mit einer schwarzen als
vize ins rennen
bled lies matter kommt zu ungeahnter
anerkennung erstmals gewinnt die
protestbewegung respekt in amerikas
mainstream
symbolische gesten für viele aktivisten
zu wenig deshalb kommen sie zusammen am
lincoln memorial
zum zweiten mal gibt es einen marsch auf
washington martin luther king 1963 ich
habe einen traum
dieser sommer der proteste hat einen
wandel im denken gebracht ein
bewusstsein geschaffen wie tief
verankert systemischer rassismus in der
gesellschaft ist bis zu tatsächliche
gleichberechtigung ist es aber noch weit
auch bei ist gekommen hin und
hergerissen zwischen der hoffnung dass
sich was ändert und wut darüber dass
bislang so wenig geschehen ist die
grundstimmung derzeit mit blick auf den
rassen konflikt die zu diesem marsch auf
washington geführt hat ist nicht viel
anders als beim ursprünglichen marsch
die geschichte fordert uns also auf
unsere wahrheit noch lauter zu verkünden
zwei minuten darf hier reden vor ganz
großem publikum die villa nutzen in die
ganze welt wird dieser marsch übertragen
die gründungsväter erschufen eine neue
nation deren leitidee die unterdrückung
war dass nicht alle menschen gleich sind
jetzt gilt es zu entscheiden ob wir
weiterhin diese nation sind oder ob
amerika sich neu erfinden kann als ein
land das gerechtigkeit für alle bietet
auf allen protesten in diesem jahr sind
viele weiße an der seite von schwarzen
es gehe in waiting durchs land heißt es
ein erwachen unter der weißen
bevölkerung
jackie hofft dass das so bleibt das
weiße nicht nur mitlaufen solange es als
cool gilt was machst du nach dem marsch
in deinem alltag um den wandel
herbeizuführen den wir wollen worauf es
ankommt ist wer morgen noch da ist
diskriminierung von schwarzen ist ein
problem das sie unbedingt lösen will
ihren juraabschluss nutzt sie dazu in
einer anwaltskanzlei rassistische
politik anzuklagen ihr geht es um
aktivismus der wirklich was verändert
[Musik]
es reicht nicht ein verbündeter zu sein
du hast ein komplize werden wenn du
nicht aktiv systemischen rassismus
bekämpfen
dann überlässt die macht denn
unterdrücker bei ist überzeugt ohne die
weißen wird es nicht gehen
die protestbewegung braucht sie ihre
unterstützung im alltag aber er ahnt
auch kein weißer wird so
leidenschaftlich kämpfen wie er der
seine hautfarbe nicht ablegen kann
ich fühle eine immense verpflichtung und
nicht nur ich ich hoffe dass meine
generation die letzte ist in diesem
kampf führen muss dass wir es schaffen
den weg zu bereiten für unsere kinder
und deren kinder
ich denke wir sind so nah dran wie wir
es in meinem leben noch nie war
es tut sich was es gibt kein zurück
diese bewegung wird amerika verändern
aber wird es das neue amerika das sich
wünscht
[Musik]
dann darf es nicht nur symptome kurieren
will amerika zur ruhe kommen muss es ein
ganz neues kapitel in seiner geschichte
aufschlagen
[Musik]
yahoo